Disney is dying and it's easy to see why.
Between the back to back flops,
burning money to supply Disney
plus, and films that just missed
the mark, Disney is in trouble.
But today I've got the solution.
And the answer that the House of Mouse is
looking for is right here
on YouTube.
Hello, Internet.
Welcome to Film Theory,
the show that won't charge you $27
million a year to fix your problems.
How's that for cost savings
there, Bob Iger.
Have you noticed that
a lot of movies have bombed recently?
Fast X underperformed.
The Flash is looking like
it will lose $200
million to Warner Brothers, making it
the biggest comic book movie bomb ever.
Even objectively, great films like Mission
Impossible: Dead Reckoning
One fell short of expectations
this summer.
But the biggest victim of the box office
bloodbath for the last two years
has got to be our mouse-eared
overlords at Walt Disney Corp.
Doctor
Strange two, Thor three, and Black Panther
two all came in under expectations.
The Little Mermaid vastly underperformed.
Both Ant-Man three, and New Indiana
Jones were also costly losers.
No one even remembers Disney's last
animated feature film Strange World
and Elemental had the lowest
opening of any modern Pixar film ever,
including Lightyear, the massive bomb
that was released right before it.
The long and short of all of this: things
are bad at the House of Mouse right now.
Disney shares are at the lowest
that they've been since COVID
hit back in March of 2020,
and to turn it all around,
they're considering selling off their
TV businesses, spinning off ESPN,
laying off thousands of employees.
We are truly
witnessing the death of the Disney Empire
happening in real time right now.
But I think that
there is a way to fix things.
And the key to it
all is YouTube. So grab your popcorn
as I prepare to tell you a story
far more compelling than anything
put out over the last few years, it's
time to fix Disney in three easy steps.
But before I help a large,
soulless corporation earn its millions
back, won't you help our small, soulful
corporation here earn some thousands back?
You can help do that
by checking out our new line of theory
wear. This isn't just merch,
these are actual clothes made specifically
with you and your life in mind,
designed to last for years
and created to help you feel amazing.
These items are cozy,
they're comfortable,
but they're also fashionable.
Case in point
if you love analog horror, then
no clip your way out of the backrooms
and into our hazmat puffer jacket.
Never before has biohazard protection
been so snuggly. Then pair that puffer
with the radioactive backpack
to keep all your dangerous
bacteria life forms safely contained
as you walk the streets.
Or if you're looking for
some infrared realness,
check out the heat map collection
black clothing with intense pops of color.
Take your pick of shorts,
hoodies, work jackets, even socks.
And for the fashion that's truly fire,
take out the new thermo reactive
t and mug, which can both change
color as they heat up.
But if all of those are a bit too loud
for your closet, check out the high res
button up. On the outside
it looks like your typical high quality
white shirt, but inside the collar, inner
button lining
and cuffs all have a classic game theory
green high tech circuit board design.
Now if only it came in red. One day,
Film Theory, one day.
We have all of this and more at our brand
new theory wear website,
which you should go check out
by clicking the link in the description
below or by checking out the merch shelf
just below this video.
Even if you don't want to buy anything,
just go check out the site.
It's actually really cool with some fun
surprises
hidden inside of it.
This year,
we're just really pushing ourselves
to do bigger, more
interesting things in the style world,
probably because we have a fashion
channel now,
and I think honestly that this is a great
first step in that.
So go check out all the awesome
new fashionable merch
that we have on the website. And hey,
what else?
Maybe one day
we'll open up a theater store
all to ourselves at the local mall here.
There's quite a few vacant
Disney locations.
They could use some new tenants
speaking up.
Let's talk
more about that Disney dilemma, shall we?
Basically, when you break it all down,
Disney's problems largely boil
down to three
major topics: streaming, budget and story.
So let's go through them point by point.
Starting with streaming.
One thing that everyone tends to overlook
when they first start a streaming service is that
you need a steady flow of content to make it work,
to keep people hooked on the platform.
And making content tends to be expensive,
hence the elongated merch push that
you just went through.
But even if you thread the needle
and managed to solve both of those issues,
making lots of content
for a relatively cheap price,
it just opens a well of new issues
that are more difficult to solve.
Let me explain.
To prevent people from bouncing off
the platform, most of Disney's Star Studios
have been relegated to content factories
to feed the Disney Plus machine.
In 2020,
Disney held an Investor Day presentation
where they had Marvel and Lucasfilm
announce ten projects each.
Pixar announced another six.
It wasn't all streaming focus,
but a whole lot of it was.
In addition,
the service has been flooded with Disney
dipping into all its other major IPs:
live action remakes of Peter Pan,
serialized versions of High School
Musical, the return of nostalgic classics
like Willow and the launch of anticipated
new IP like Artemis Fowl.
Disney owns
some of the most beloved IP on the planet,
and they've been pulling it
all off the shelves to try and keep
their content offering on Disney
plus robust and most importantly, sticky,
to keep all those finicky streaming audiences
that are quick to cancel a subscription.
Despite it being difficult and expensive
to stay on that online content treadmill,
at least on the surface,
it looks like Disney managed
to thread the needle. But in achieving
that, they've actually expose themselves
to a problem that's far worse:
brand dilution.
There's no arguing that pretty much
every single one of these cherished
franchises has become significantly
less special over the last
five years, simply because there's
just so much of them around at this point.
Toy Story four,
Lightyear, Toy Story five,
you can only go to the pump so many times
before the audience can smell a shameless
cash grab.
Going back to those Investor Day
announcements, most of the Star Wars ones,
they were quietly canceled.
A completely different episode
nine, a Boba Fett
solo movie, a trilogy from Rian Johnson,
another trilogy from the Game of Thrones
guys. When something new from Star Wars
gets announced, at this point,
there's little trust
that it's ever going
to see the light of day
and even less trust
that it's going to be good.
Andor, for instance,
it was legitimately great.
Seriously, it was the single best thing
that Star Wars has produced in years.
But you know why no one and watched it?
Because it was buried
under a slew of underwhelming projects
like the Book of Boba Fett,
Obi-Wan Kenobi, Late Season Mandalorian,
and episode
nine. People lost trust with the brand
and as a result, deprioritized
watching all the new stuff
that was rolling out. And the MCU?
It's having the exact same issue right now.
Look at this: phase one had 746
minutes of content spread over five years,
phase two 757 minutes spread over three years,
and then you had phase three at 1500
minutes spread over another three years.
That was a pretty significant jump,
but it was nothing compared to phase four.
Thanks in part
to the introduction of Disney Plus
and the requirement for streaming content,
Phase four had a staggering
3500 minutes spread across only two years.
There's been more MCU content in the last
two years than the preceding 12 combined.
A Marvel release used to feel like
an event like you had to see it.
Nowadays, though,
it's quite literally a weekly occurrence.
So of course
people are going to be less excited
for new installments like Secret Invasion,
regardless of their quality.
Don't worry, we're going to address
the quality here in a second.
What's worse,
in their drive to Disney plus,
the mouse has lost out on a lot of money.
They probably didn't
need to. Looking at the list of original films
created and released by Disney,
so many of them are going straight
to Disney plus without making any money
in a theater. This year alone across all
their studios, six of the 14 Disney films
so far have premiered directly on Disney
Plus or Hulu, with no additional cost.
In 2022, a whopping 27 premiered on
streaming and only 16 were in theaters.
Now compare all that to 2018, the year
before Disney Plus launched,
where Disney released
only ten films total, all of which
obviously went to the theaters.
Not only do these streaming premieres
mean that they're losing a lot of money
from the theatrical window,
but it becomes an even bigger issue
when you combine it with our next
major problem: budgeting. The budgets
for so many modern blockbusters
and especially those made by Disney,
are just out of control.
Indiana Jones and the Dial of Destiny
cost $300 million to make. Guardians three
and the little Mermaid,
$250 million each.
Quantumania, a cool 200 mil. They even spent $150
million on Haunted Mansion.
Why would you spend
$150 million on a Haunted Mansion movie?
And the true number
is probably more like $300 million
if you include the marketing for it.
Even Disney's animation
wing isn't safe. Both Encanto
and Strange World cost somewhere between
$135 and $180 million to make.
While almost all of Pixar's
latest releases put their budgets
between $150 and $200 and range.
Now, you might be looking at all those
numbers and thinking, Wow, that's a lot.
But aren't all movies super expensive?
And the answer is yes, but also no.
Yeah,
they cost hundreds of millions of dollars,
but not that many hundreds
of millions of dollars.
When you look at other massive
blockbusters currently in theaters,
most are not looking like this.
Oppenheimer had a massive cast
and incredible experimental
filmmaking techniques, and it cost
just $100 million to make. John Wick four
elaborate action sequences with top tier
stunt work and incredible set designs
at multiple real world locations
also cost just $100 million.
Barbie is the biggest movie of the summer.
It has iconic art direction,
detailed fictional worlds with real sets
and A-list actors who enjoyed being there.
And it was made for less than $150
million. Over on the animation side,
the newly released Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles movie cost $70 million
while Puss in Boots,
The Last Wish, and Across the Spider-Verse,
and the Super Mario Brothers
movie were all at about $100 mil each.
All of these are half to a third of what
Disney is paying to make their movies.
And it doesn't take a rocket scientist
to understand that it's a lot easier
to get back what you put in
when you're only $70 million in the hole
as opposed to $200 million.
All of this begs
the question of why, though?
Why are these movies so expensive?
Well, it's complicated.
And it ultimately comes down
to a lot of different factors:
an overreliance on CGI, a push to develop
new technologies, writing
that just doesn't keep budgets in mind.
But one of the biggest contributors
to the inflation
of a movie's budget over at Disney
that a lot of people
don't talk about are reshoots.
A reshoot is where a film brings back
the cast and crew to refilm scenes
that didn't work
or to film new scenes that become needed
as they get into the editing process.
Don't get me wrong,
reshoots are a perfectly normal
part of production
and they can really help
bring a movie together.
A lot of very successful
films have had reshoots:
Back to the Future,
ET, Rocky that's not the sort of stuff
I'm talking about here.
What I'm talking about is when a movie
studio sees the rough cut of a movie,
gets cold feet and then suddenly decides
they basically need to start over
from scratch.
Probably the most famous example of this
was with Zack Snyder's Justice League.
But Disney,
they too have been guilty of this
a lot lately.
Most publicly with Solo a Star Wars story.
Originally,
that movie was directed by Phil
Lord and Chris Miller, the two guys behind
Spider-Verse and The Lego Movie.
But Disney didn't like what they saw,
and so they hired Ron Howard to reshoot
an estimated 80% of the movie, thereby
doubling its budget
to somewhere around $300 million.
Now, as we all know,
Solo did not do super well.
It only grossed about $400 million
worldwide, a number that suddenly becomes
a lot less painful to look at if
your original budget was just $125 million.
But all the streaming
and budgeting changes in
the world are going to be useless
if they continue to fail.
At our third main
point: story. So many Disney films lately
have been failing at making a story
that's both worth telling
and that audiences want to hear.
Disney keeps hoping
that you can still slap a brand name
on to something, and it'll sell,
but that just doesn't work anymore.
Audiences aren't stupid.
They can tell when a story is being told
just because the bean counters
think it's going to make money.
Like, who asked for Zootopia
two, Frozen
three, Inside Out two, Toy Story five?
All of those are real movies
that are happening in the near future,
even though it feels like that
list should be a parody.
But making unnecessary sequels
is just the tip of the iceberg.
Disney also doesn't understand
where their stories fit anymore.
Look no further than the Eternals,
which introduced a dozen new characters
and 10,000 years of back story
into a two hour film.
Why wasn't this a Disney plus series
that could have given the concept time to breathe?
Meanwhile, they're clearly stretching out
stories that don't need to be TV shows.
The Obi-Wan series
is a great example of this.
There was a really strong core
narrative there about Obi-Wan's
relationship to Vader
that ultimately got buried under
the bloatware of side quests and subplots.
And hey, wouldn't you know it?
Obi Wan was originally written
to be a two hour film that they decided
to turn into a six hour series.
If you want a super recent
example: Secret Invasion in which, man,
I have no idea what Marvel
was thinking on this one.
Let's take this iconic storyline
from the comics with an Avengers level
threat and adapted into a spy thriller
with basically no spying, no thrills,
and no Avengers.
What should have been this amazing
tentpole moment of the Avengers
line of films...
I mean, who doesn't love themselves
a good impostor storyline... became yet
another piece of wasted
potential content
to further dilute the MCU brand on Disney
Plus. And again, here's the problem
when you start
dumping out a lot of content all at once
just to keep us on the digital treadmill:
people start to see patterns.
They see the trends,
the formulas that you're using.
For example, with so many Big Temple
Disney releases lately
had a main character becoming jaded
just because they lost a loved one.
It happened with Han Solo, Luke Skywalker,
Indiana Jones, Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Heck,
even Haunted Mansion in Secret Invasion,
which you probably shouldn't know,
because why would you ever bother
to see those things?
This generation of stories has seen
our fictional heroes become miserable,
and let's be real,
that is not something that fans
want to see.
We fell in love
with these characters for a reason.
They inspired us for a reason.
Seeing them crushed
under the same depression of reality
that we real people face
every day is not fun.
Sure, it might be more realistic
to see a disillusioned Indiana Jones,
but audiences go to the movies
to escape from reality,
to believe in something better,
something greater,
to have something to hope for
and aspire to.
And Disney is no longer providing those
hopeful messages.
So that's a lot of doom and gloom, right?
Is there any way that Disney
and really the entire film
industry can fix all these issues?
Well, yeah, actually. All you've got to do:
treat it like a YouTube channel.
What I mean to say
is that they need to program
their slate of movies
just like you do a YouTube channel.
I'm going to let you in on a little secret
here, loyal theorist,
we spend a lot of time thinking about what
theories we put up across
all the different channels.
With multiple weekly meetings
trying to figure out what would work best
where, planning out
when things should go up,
and what videos complement each other,
all for the overall health
of the business.
You can't just throw up a video willy
nilly and hope everything goes
well these days.
No, you need to make sure
that you have solid videos here
and there to keep the system
and your viewers happy.
And everything we talked about today
with Disney are things that regularly
come up in our day to day conversations
about how to run things here at THEORIST.
First of all, we have a quality bar
that episodes just have to hit, otherwise
they're not going to get made.
Our primary metric in the success
or failure of a video isn't revenue,
it's actually you, the community.
Could we make more money
by pumping out more episodes every week? Probably.
But in the process we would burn you out
and by necessity, dilute the show
as we greenlight worse
and worse episodes. See in YouTube analytics,
they give you a handy little chart ranking
your most recent releases from 1 to 10 in
terms of how well it's performing.
Well, ideally, every upload
you do is going to be a one out of ten.
It's just not realistic
to have that sort of expectation.
In the end, something is inevitably
going to be a ten out of ten.
And if you're good at what you do,
you know when those nines and tens
are going to hit,
and so you have to surround
that low performer
with stuff
that you know is going to do well.
Otherwise, your risk taking L after L
after L and you start making a narrative
about how bad your stuff is now,
how much it's fallen off.
Or worse, the algorithm decides that
people no longer care about your channel.
Apply this concept to Disney
and you immediately
see what they have to do with their IP.
When you have back to back
to back to back
disappointments line up
like in Marvel's recent roster,
it creates a downward spiral
that's pretty hard to break
in the public consciousness.
But if you mix in one or two goods
with the bad strategically,
suddenly it's much harder
to craft a doom and gloom narrative.
Here's an example
programing lineup: Multiverse of Madness,
Wakanda Forever, Guardians three, Love
and Thunder, Quantumania.
That looks a lot different
from what really happened where Guardians
three appeared at the end.
The real release order gave
you four disappointments in a row before
you got a small pick me up with
the generally well-received Guardians.
But if Guardians had been in the middle,
the disappointments
are suddenly broken up.
There's a gap there.
The lackluster movies on either
side of it, it's just a franchise cost
and long waiting for the next big event.
In fact, I can make this programing lineup
even better if Wakanda Forever
had actually been first in the list.
The mediocre performance of Wakanda
actually was made significantly worse
by the disappointment of Multiverse
of Madness that came directly before.
Had it come before Doctor Strange,
that movie wouldn't have been saddled
with all the extra scrutiny of "Is Marvel
losing its way?",
"if Wakanda Forever isn't good
it means it's the end of Marvel," thereby
leading
to a different cultural conversation
around it.
Release order matters
when it comes to shaping the narrative
around your brand, and it matters a lot.
The same thing
holds true for any experimental episodes.
Disney needs to be making films
about new IP like Pixar's Elio or lesser
known characters
like Marvel's Moon Knight.
But obviously those projects are going to
be risky, so you balance that risk out by
putting them between other projects
you expect to do well.
Your Toy Story
five's, your Avengers, your Guardians.
This accomplishes
three things all at once:
you mitigate your risk,
you spread out the quote
unquote cash grabs, and you potentially
find your next explosive IP.
Again,
let's look at Film Theory for an example.
On this channel,
we have a few relatively sure things
our tentpole programing: analog horror,
Spider-Man, nostalgic kid shows,
and knowing
that we're able to put the stuff
that we're not sure about between them.
And then if something surprises you
and it does manage to explode... BAM!
You have yourself a new strong subject
to slot other unknowns
in between. That is literally
what happened to us with the Backrooms.
We weren't sure that one was going to do
and it ended up doing gangbusters
with people wanting more
and more of our analysis videos
while they wear their new absurdly
comfortable theorywear
hazmat puffer jacket. The gamble
paid off and it paid off in a big way.
But we also know that we can't release
too many of those things
in too quick of succession.
We can't release a Backrooms theory
every single week
because even though they'll do well,
people will eventually stop caring
if we do too much
and they'll stop coming back
because we're no longer adding
anything to the conversation.
Does that sound familiar,
Star Wars? How about you, Marvel?
Can you relate?
And just in general,
when running a YouTube channel,
you got to know what episode ideas
are going to work best as shorts
and which ones merit a full video.
We don't try to take something
that's clearly a short
and then bloated into a full 15 minute
video or vice versa.
Just like Disney
shouldn't be looking at something
that's clearly an hour and a half movie
and trying to turn it into a ten episode
miniseries just so they get more
watch minutes on their streaming app.
Content needs to fit where it tells
the best story.
Lastly, in terms of our budgeting,
we have to make sure that an episode
can make back the money
that we're spending on making it pay
and the writers and editors
that are working on it and we budget it
just based on the ad sense
we expect to make from that video.
Anything extra
that we get from brand deals
or merch sales or whatever is a nice plus.
It allows us to expand the team
to do more ambitious projects,
but we can't budget every single video
that way because eventually
we're going to lose that bet
and we can't run the business anymore.
Think of our AdSense like your box office,
Disney. Sure,
every now and then
we could do a more expensive video,
something that takes a bit more time,
or just invest in a passion project.
That's going to be maybe a once or twice
a year thing, not an every release thing.
Disney, you can't keep releasing $300
million movie after $300 million movie
without knowing that you're going to earn
that back at the box office. Budget
according to what you know
you're going to earn in the theaters
that way, all the ancillary stuff,
that's all gravy.
Anything you earn on top of that,
boom, it's a bonus.
You became that much more profitable.
You know, it's going to help with that?
Fixing your reshoot issue.
Let me tell you, as
I was researching this episode,
just as someone running a media company,
my jaw hit the floor
when I saw how often companies like Disney
are doing reshoots that majorly overhaul
the movie.
How are you rolling on day one
without having a clear vision
that the writers, directors, producers
and studio have all agreed to?
At theorist
we don't do an episode
unless all of our senior creative
team are on the same page
about what that episode is going to be.
And more importantly,
when we work with brands,
we require that every single stakeholder
review and lock the script
before shooting begins.
That way,
no one can ask for a last minute change.
We learned early that those reshoots
and re-edits cost a fortune,
killing our process.
But by forcing everyone
to get on the same page early,
even if it's painful and slows
the process down
a bit at the beginning, it saves so much
time, money and a ton of headaches
on the other, much more expensive
end of the production process.
All in all, in their desperate bid
to try to catch up
to Netflix with their streaming service,
throwing money at their problems in hopes
that they'll go away, Disney
lost sight of what made entertainment work
since the very beginning:
making what you can,
making what you're good at,
keeping it on budget and telling a story
that's worth telling. And if we here on
YouTube can do it, they have no excuse.
Or if they can't get their act together,
even the death of Disney
was ultimately for the best.
But hey,
remember,
go check out that new line of theory
wear. Again,
I cannot stress enough
just how much work went
into all these items
because we wanted this to be more
than just your typical YouTuber merch,
like, well, just slap the logo on it.
No, these are actual clothing items
that have high quality fabric expert
details and stuff that's going to make you
feel incredible when you wear it.
So please do me a favor:
go check out all the cool stuff
that we made
by heading on over to our theory wear
website links in the description below.
Or maybe it's on screen right now.
I don't know.
Maybe through the magic of editing
we can make that happen.
And as always, my friends, until next
time, remember, it's all just a theory,
a Film Theory! And cut.